when you first sign on to write that
book what were you most nervous about in
terms of being able to do your work the
way you want while adhering to certain
expectations that were already set by a
widely beloved animated classic all of
that I'm also realizing now I should
have called you and been like Melissa
Health
um first of all when they reached out
similarly they reached out
um to ask if I could write the prequel
to The Little Mermaid movie I thought it
was an April Fool's joke like I thought
my agent was playing just because it's
the first Little Mermaid where Ariel
looks like me and so to have the
opportunity to write the prequel to that
story was just historic and I was just
blown away that they thought I could do
it
um so I signed on I said okay and then
at that point it was the price it was
literally the pressure of I am writing a
story to describe so against the type is
Ariel's life before she breaks the
surface of the water so it's what led to
creating the Ariel who wanted to collect
things and wanted to break the surface
of the water who was so excited to to
rescue Eric like how did that person
come to be and so I got to decide that
and it was so much pressure because at
the end of the day like the cool thing
about art in movies and in books is that
we sort of as the consumer of that art
like we sort of own that art how we
interpret it and what it means to us is
very personal and so I felt this
pressure like I'm deciding what Ariel's
life is going to be like like who am I
to decide that but eventually I was like
the deadline I've been chosen
oh my gosh the deadline was my editor is
incredible
um fun fact I'd never met my editor in
person until tonight or today I ran into
her outside so but um I the deadline was
looming so I just one foot in front of
the other it just was so much pressure I
was really afraid to get
um her personality wrong like I wanted
to make Ariel pretty sassy and I was
afraid that I get pushed back like that
doesn't sound like her but I'm like it's
been like how many years since the first
one came out like Shirley 2023 area only
have some sass so I went there and they
were pretty forgiving they let me do
kind of like what you're saying like
this can't happen this thing can't talk
but it gave me creative Liberty a lot of
creative Liberty I'm a shout out
something you didn't reference just now
because one of my favorite things ever
is a lot of people who even if they love
the movie they walked away saying one
particular thing over and over I wish
the movie had more of her sisters your
book tells their story also and I just
absolutely love that quality so if I
include that and the millions of other
things you have to do in this book what
like extension did you have to yeah that
like came most naturally to you where
you saw it you're like yeah I know
exactly how to expand that but then on
the other hand what was something where
you know like maybe you felt a little
creatively boxed in and you really just
sit and think about the way to break out
of that box so I think the most boxed in
piece was was Ariel because I felt like
I needed to write the aerial that we all
know
um she needed to sound like Ariel she
needed to think like Ariel but I'm also
like it's 20 23 girl you sound a little
bit different these days don't you and
so it was like how do I modernize her I
did have access to the movie script so I
was able to see
yes they they did give me because they
wanted me to see how the film how the
film was different so that I could write
into it and so I think that helped but
it was that was probably the hardest
part is making Ariel feel like Ariel
there were points where my editor was
like
um Ariel is really inquisitive can she
ask more questions here and I realized
in that moment I was holding back
because I was afraid to really step in
and like be Ariel and like think for
Ariel
um but then the coolest part was
probably kind of like you were saying
Melissa as writers as fantasy writers we
like to make up our own stories from our
imagination and so one of the things
that I got to create is like where these
sisters reside because they don't all in
and against the tide they don't all live
in Atlantica at the palace they all have
their own territories and so I got to
create
um several different oceans that have
their own sort of geography like one of
them
um Karina is from this particular ocean
where the seaweed is made of icicle and
the water has like snow on top and so
her hair is like very white and she has
this cool like magic ability that deals
with being in cold temperatures so I got
to like make up the wildest things about
these different places the sisters were
from and make them all unique and that
was great because I was like it's a
blank slate and I do well with a blank
slate